a rep for khloe kardashian tells e.t
she's expecting her second child in
november via surrogate
meanwhile a source as the father is
tristan thompson
the exes are parents to four-year-old
daughter true here is what we know the
source explains quote when the two were
on good terms they decided to move
forward with surrogacy near the end of
last year
and then tristan was caught cheating
in december it was revealed tristan
fathered a child with personal trainer
marlene nichols
fans watched the scandal appear on the
kardashians
fine
did you see what i sent you no hang on
what
what is this so he's been lying to you
what
now the source does note that quote the
two aren't together and chloe will have
the baby full time
but chloe wants tristan in both the kids
lives as much as he wants to be
and as she said in the past chloe's all
for doing what's best for little true
people do make mistakes and i don't you
know he's still a good person he's not a
good partner right he's always going to
be in my life because of true and he's a
great dad
and you know that's really all i need to
focus on is just his relationship with
true when it comes to chloe and tristan
surrogate her rep tells us quote chloe
is incredibly grateful to the
extraordinary surrogate for such a
beautiful blessing adding quote we'd
like to ask for kindness and privacy so
that chloe can focus on her family
this latest development might have fans
wondering if they'll see it play out on
the series
as chloe previously explained to e.t she
plans to be an open book but everyone
has their limits
is there anything you won't show or are
there no boundaries i think for every
sister we have different boundary levels
and we all try to respect that and
probably moving forward we might all
have and like your boundaries are
allowed to change and mine will probably
change later but
i'm also i think a lot of us are you
know what is in the media is sort of
things that we feel we need to film
because it's
in a way unfair to the viewers if they
don't get to see that we've shared so
much about our lives so i think moving
forward things might change with me but
who knows i am an open book and i like
to be that way but
it can change at any time
[Music]